Tell me why you're here.
What are you doing in this country?
This country has always been
a place that people come
to find themselves,
and to find their dreams.
The stories of immigrants
coming to the United States
are both incredibly unique,
but also universal.
Life is full of comedy and drama,
and sometimes those things
live side by side.
It says here you got permission
for an expedited wedding…
because you are
eight months pregnant?
Yes.
What happens when you come here
and you have a dream-
This place is like a jail.
And that dream doesn't work out.
Everyone struggles.
And sometimes success
comes in different ways.
All these women come into your shop,
you make them feel like
the best version of themselves.
Why can’t you do that for yourself?
Whether we come here or we grew up here,
I think everybody can see themselves
in these stories.
Before you even saw a piano,
you were better than most pianists.
This is such a beautiful portrait
of the tapestry of
immigrant experiences in America.
This is our life now,
and I love it.
Go!
Ahh!